foreign
yeah so it's a song that was trained on
the voice of Drake in it sounds
remarkably like him but it's not his
lyrics it's not his song so this is a
great example kind of coming into the us
right now where there is a song that is
made to sound like the musician Drake
you know it was trained potentially on
his voice everything about the labeling
of it online says this was an AI song
made using Drake's likeness and so we're
already seeing that umg the kind of
massive music company that pulls the
license to this music is sending
requests to major corporations to take
it down right Spotify has already taken
me down Apple's already taken it down
and I believe Google took it down via
YouTube but then it went back up and it
hasn't gone down again since because the
big question here is the song itself is
not copyrighted this is a new song
created but it's a new song created
using a similar voice to an artist and
so this is a great example of that a
mountain substance right it is not the
song it is not the lyrics it is not the
beat it is a very similar sounding voice
that potentially could be mistaken as
the voice of a of an artist
can that be copyrighted can you predict
what is considered style in some cases
could you protect the style of something
via copyright is an issue that generally
in the US we do not protect style but
certainly that conversation is going to
start having happening as it relates to
AI